hey everyone just a quick note sheila
sent me a short audio note after our
conversation which i am going to share
at the end of this episode with her
permission it has a 60 day challenge
slash experiment slash mission for me
and my girlfriend and all that will make
sense after you listen to the interview
and my hope is that it will also help a
lot of you
listening to this conversation so make
sure to stick around after the end of
the episode to listen to the details of
that 60 day challenge and without
further ado please enjoy
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
my guest today is sheila heen this
s-h-e-i-l-a-h-e-e-n
sheila is a new york times best-selling
author founder of triad consulting group
and a deputy director of the harvard
negotiation project at harvard law
school where she has been a member of
the faculty for 25 years sheila
specializes in particularly difficult
negotiations where emotions run high and
relationships become strained she often
works with executive teams helping them
to resolve conflict repair professional
relationships and make sound decisions
together i also have a lot of drama in
my own life that perhaps we'll end up
exploring but back to the bio in the
public sector
she has provided training for the new
england organ bank the singapore supreme
court the obama white house and
theologians struggling with disagreement
over the nature of truth and god we will
almost certainly come back to that
sheila is co-author of the new york
times bestsellers difficult
conversations subtitle how to discuss
what matters most and thanks for the
feedback subtitled the science and art
of receiving feedback well and then
parentheses even when it's off base
unfair poorly deliberate and frankly
you're not in the mood and parentheses
she has written for the harvard business
review in the new york times as a guest
expert and contributor to the modern
love column and she's appeared on npr
fox news nbc's power lunch and shows as
diverse as oprah and the g gordon liddy
show she has spoken at the global
leadership summit the nordic business
forum the smithsonian apple google and
microsoft sheila is a graduate of
occidental college and harvard law
school she is schooled in negotiation
daily by her three children a problem i
look forward to having myself and her
website is triad consulting group you
can find both triad consulting group and
sheilahin on linkedin sheila welcome to
the show
i am so delighted to be here
i thought we would start
with
the forward of difficult conversations
which is written by roger fisher could
you please describe for us who roger was
oh golly how can i
capture for your listeners who roger was
roger was just an incredibly
inspirational person
so he
fought in world war ii
and he was in both the atlantic and the
pacific theaters
um he was actually a weatherman so they
would send up a plane they didn't have
weather satellites right so they send up
a weather plane
to check out the weather over germany
and then that where they radio back to
say whether you should send out the
mission
being in the air force during world war
ii was not a super survivable place to
be um and when roger came back from the
war he found that
he had lost several college roommates
friends
he was the only one who came home in his
immediate social circle if you go to
memorial church on the
harvard college campus
the walls are etched with names
of harvard students and graduates so
some of them didn't graduate before they
died who have
who have died in service of our country
and it would be fascinating just to
stand there
and talk with him he would point to
names and say oh this guy was so funny
you know and this guy was just the most
generous person i had ever met
and i think that that experience really
motivated the rest of his life he came
back and
dedicated his life to trying to find
better ways for us to manage conflict in
the world and his passion was
international relations right so he
would sit down and read the paper in the
morning the newspaper of course was how
we got our news back
um even when i turned up on the scene in
the in the 90s
and
he would find a conflict and he would
just start working on it and then he
would fax his advice off to the leaders
involved they'd be getting these faxes
from some guy named roger who who had
some kind of interesting ideas so every
once in a while someone would call him
back and that's how he got involved in
border disputes between peru and ecuador
that's how he got involved in south
africa with the anc and the white
government just before the
constitutional talks
that's how he got involved in ireland um
and and it's also how he came to write
getting to yes which is the negotiation
book that really became a foundation
book in the field of negotiation and
conflict resolution
so you mentioned entering the scene how
did you enter the scene with respect to
negotiation and conflict resolution
well it was funny because i went to i
grew up in
iowa and nebraska and through a series
of
sort of serendipitous accidents i ended
up at occidental college in california
for college and when i was applying to
law school
ultimately i was trying to decide
whether
whether to go to stanford or harvard
because of course i didn't get into yale
which is true of almost every person
who's listening to this podcast so we
all have that in common
and one of my college advisors said to
me you know
harvard is the bigger and kind of
scarier choice
i hear you saying but they have this
negotiation thing and i just have an
instinct that it might be up your alley
and probably partly because it was the
bigger and scarier thing but also
because
i felt he knew me pretty well
i decided to come to harvard i didn't
know anybody
and of course he was right i took
negotiation my very first year of law
school and just fell in love
with the field i just thought
wow i could learn something new every
day for the rest of my life
what did you love about it
i think partly that it was so
interdisciplinary
so
when we're trying to understand
something we're reaching in all
directions right behavioral economics
neuroscience
psychology social psychology
you're really reaching in all directions
just to understand the human aspects of
working relationships and problem
solving and what gets in the way
and that means as each of those fields
advances and we understand more in each
of those fields
well we get to capitalize on that to
think well how would this apply um to
how we
manage the inevitable conflict in all of
our relationships with professional
relationships and personal relationships
so i'm learning every day not only
because of my own shortcomings which
become
sharper and clearer every day it seems
but also um also because i i get to
stand on the shoulders of so many people
who are like hey this is really
interesting and i think to myself wow
that is really interesting i wonder how
that applies
and you're off and running again
so when
listeners hear
the phrase
difficult or i suppose term although
it's multi words i would never never
know what to call something that's two
words a phrasal term in any case
tomato tomato difficult conversations
especially since i
discussed business so much on this
podcast i have guests on who specialize
in business they probably think of a
certain
siloed breed of difficult conversation
that may be the first thing that comes
to mind
but
i would love to hear you tell the story
i only got
the skeleton
overview of this in reading for this
conversation
of
your trip to los angeles to renew your
passport
i don't know if that ring is any bells
but yeah uh if if you wouldn't mind
filling in the color for that
we could start there yeah let's start
there
well
on the business side
i will say that difficult conversations
come at you from every direction right
they're with your subordinates with your
peers with your boss with your
partners and vendors etc and often you
see them coming down the pike or you're
wondering whether to have them but every
once in a while they ambush you kind of
out of nowhere and and i think that's
what happened to me that day in los
angeles so i
where was i going i guess i was going to
spain um because we were going over to
teach negotiation
and i was still a student but i had been
invited to
go and be part of the harvard
negotiation program that was teaching a
week in madrid
so i had to go to renew my passport and
i was working that summer in los angeles
so i went down to the federal building
which is near ucla
and
did whatever i did there
that you know we're all probably
familiar with and then i was i got in
the elevator to come down and i was on a
pretty high floor
and the elevator filled packed
and on the way down to the lobby
a guy in the elevator just started
ranting saying the most
upsetting
and
vile racist
stuff and
my mind has completely blanked out on
exactly what he said
but i do recall that i had never you
know i'm a sheltered kid from nebraska i
had never heard even some of these
things before
and he was going on and on and on as we
clicked slowly down the floors
in a packed elevator of people from all
over the world
and
it was silent
and by the time the doors opened on the
lobby and everyone sort of with relief
spilled out
of that confined space where you just
felt trapped and unable to breathe
i was shaking
and i was thinking oh my goodness what
what could i have done what should i
have done i didn't
i didn't know what to do and
was i responsible for saying something
or not
and and what was
what was interesting was that it has
stuck with me i'm like shaking now i'm
thinking about it
it has stuck with me
all these years it wasn't aimed at me
clearly
i'm white
and
yet it stuck with me so viscerally that
i ended up writing my third year paper
about it so to to graduate from harvard
law school at that time you needed to do
a pretty big
research paper
during your third year and i i decided
to do it on that interaction just to
better understand
what was it that was
happening what was i experiencing what
was i noticing
what were my diagnoses for what was
going on what was i
should i have spoken up who was i trying
to influence or persuade
or even if i
wasn't going to persuade him of anything
was i speaking up on other people's
behalf or was i just speaking up for
myself so that i could come out of that
interaction
with some sense of self-respect
for sticking up for something
and what was i risking
in any of those interactions what would
be my
purpose and what might be at risk
and um i think i really see in that
paper
a few of the germs of what later became
the book difficult conversations
simultaneous to that unbeknownst to me i
was writing that paper for bruce patton
who is a co-author and getting ts and
and was supervising the paper
and unbeknownst to me at the time he and
doug stone
were already themselves working on
what were we learning about difficult
conversations so by the time i graduated
and they offered me a full-time job
to join them at the negotiation project
we were all kind of thinking about and
wrestling with some of those same
questions
so i want to bring in a
third player so to speak
there are many different
types of difficult conversations
and then i'm going to ask about
how to tie them together
theologians struggling with disagreement
over the nature
of truth and god
now this seems like the type of
disagreement that could go on and maybe
in fact has gone on for thousands and
thousands and thousands of years so it
would seem also that
there are
clearly difficult conversations where
not only is it incredibly
hard to get to a right answer or a
resolution there may not even in fact be
a right answer so to speak now that
could be very different from resolution
maybe there is a resolution just no
right answer so my understanding is that
you
write and speak on how every difficult
conversation is the same underlying
structure
what do you mean by that what ties these
things together how are they
how are they similar
yeah great question by the way i i spent
i think it was about 15 hours locked in
a room with six theologians with
disagreements over the truth nature of
truth and god and and i got that all
figured out now so oh nice nice
i look forward to reading that book
yeah exactly well i'm not going to tell
you guys i mean come on
um
yeah i actually i should pause there
because there's
one of the theologians dominic said
something so profound in the nature in
the course of that conversation that um
it stuck with me all these years
part of what emerged from the
conversation was if we're made in the
image of god
what does that mean for each of us what
do we each think that means and one of
the things that came out was the idea
that
if our souls are partly the nature of
god maybe it's that we have thousand
watt souls
but as human beings we only have 40 watt
bulbs
that we're able to plug into that so we
understand and show so little of the
light that is possible there
um and that that image really has stayed
with me that maybe maybe part of the
journey
of getting better at difficult
conversations and getting better at
understanding
humanity and our relationships with each
other and our own limitations and
understanding each other
and i i think
that learning
happens between us
that the way that you learn about
yourself the way you might learn about
god or the universe or the nature of
life is in that space between
you and me
and that's where the struggle often is
but you asked a more analytical question
which i will also i will also um respond
to oh i'm happy to go way far
into the into the ether with the other
types of questions but we can also we
can also just
get get a toehold with the analytical
if we want to start there
yeah well and be and that's been one of
the things that's been really fun about
this field is is that
it is both incredibly rigorously
analytical
and
it has to do with who we are and what we
think the meaning of life is and the
emotions that we carry into all of our
conversations and relationships whether
we're aware of them or not
so
when we first started working on the
book
bruce and doug and i that became
difficult conversations the working
title was actually
the 10 hardest things to say and how to
say them
yeah
because we figured i don't know there's
probably like 8 or 10 or 12 different
types of difficult conversations right
and a conversation with your boss would
be different than a conversation with
your partner or your spouse and that'd
be different than a conversation with
your teenager
which is probably a volume unto itself
and so we'll just figure out what those
different types of conversations are
that implies conversations with your
teenager
fair enough
that is fair enough
so um
or conversations where they're listening
to anything you say it's a one-sided
conversation
so we figure we'll we'll just figure out
what those different types of
conversations are and we'll have a
chapter about each and this is great
because people buy books with titles
like that
and so this is a fabulous plan
we quickly ran into a little bit of
trouble because we realized that we were
wrong
that actually it didn't matter who you
are talking to and it doesn't matter
what you're talking about
the same kinds of things show up in our
internal voice in any difficult
conversation meaning
the internal voice is what we're
thinking and feeling
but may not be saying to each other
and those fall into three categories
so the first is that we're each thinking
about
what's happening what has happened what
is happening right now and what should
happen so this is sort of our s the
story we tell about the facts
quote-unquote facts because it's really
an interpretation but
um and that includes what i'm right
about
who's right but usually what i'm right
about
whose fault it is that we're having this
problem
and also what your intentions or
motivations or character are like why
are you being so impossible why are you
being so stupid or difficult and those
are the three pieces of the story that
i'm telling about you but by the way
you're telling the same story about me
well a different story with the same
elements um you're focused on what
you're right about and
whose fault it is which is clearly
yours no you think it's mine
and why the other person's acting this
way so that's one level of the
conversation but there are two more
things going on beneath the surface the
second is that we're
by the time somebody becomes a difficult
conversation we're each usually
struggling with a whole host of feelings
of frustration betrayal confusion
guilt shame
anxiety
and
what do we do with those feelings often
we don't address them directly
we they simply infuse the conversation
that the energy that drives the
conversation and feelings get translated
into blame and arguments and accusations
and if we don't talk about them often
we're not getting to the heart of what's
going on because by the time even in
business by the time becomes a difficult
conversation
typically we've got at least two
problems one is the surface problem like
you know is this timeline realistic
we're arguing about that
is this the right strategy
going forward
who's right about that
but there's a second problem beneath
that which is how we each feel treated
by the other
which is that i've been telling you that
these timelines aren't realistic forever
and yet you keep blaming me for missing
them um because you're just not willing
to listen
and if we don't address how we each feel
treated
we might
resolve the surface problem but that
deeper problem is going to turn up in a
different form right next week or next
month
so
you've got
what happened conversation we call it in
the book the second is the feelings
conversation and then at the deepest
level is what we call the identity
conversation
and the idea here is that if a
conversation feels difficult chances are
there's something the situation suggests
about you that feels
troubling
or at stake or maybe
a little bit true
or maybe infuriatingly wrong but there's
it's not just that we're arguing about
money it's always about more than money
it's about whether i'm respected or
competent or a good person or worthy of
love even
and that's part of why these
conversations feel so high stakes
so the identity component
there's the what happened
component there's the feelings
conversation
as you mentioned then the identity is
how it affects how we
view ourselves how others view us or how
we view
others that's right and so here's a
simple example for people who have
trouble saying no
well that doesn't seem that hard just
say no more often you've probably gotten
that advice a million times right
but
it's not that you don't know how to say
the word no it's that chances are you
think of yourself as somebody who is
very loyal
or generous or all you know would never
abandon a friend in need well if that's
true then anytime someone asks you for
help
turning them down for that help is isn't
just
saying the word no it's doing something
that feels in conflict or intention with
who you
want to be in the world
and someone letting you know that you
let them down
will be a much harder conversation for
you than for someone who just doesn't
happen to have that identity story about
themselves right the guy in the office
next door has no trouble saying no to
everybody which of course why everybody
comes to you
because they know you'll say yes
so
that also helped us understand why is it
that some people have trouble with some
conversations and the same conversation
is easy for someone else
and it's partly because of whatever the
story is that you tell about yourself
and who you are trying to be
and once you have an understanding of
uh the three conversations which is in a
way it's kind of a meta anatomy of each
conversation right yeah it's like the
underlying structure of any difficult
conversation in the world
so once you have that x-ray vision and
you're able to
look at conversations through the lens
of these three
conversations does that then turn into a
checklist or an approach how do you
translate that into
thinking about
how to address
or prepare for a given conversation yeah
so
um i think that they
that structure mostly serves as
landmarks
so i think that the way that we often
will well if you're like me
prepare quote unquote prepare for a
difficult conversation is that we lie
awake worrying about it
and
uh maybe we turn on the light and jot
down a few talking points right and then
we think about how they're going to
react and
then we think about our rebuttals right
to their reactions and we're sort of
charting a path like i'm going to say
this and then i know they're going to
say this so i'll respond with this etc
we're turning a path through the woods
to try to get to the other side
and by the way
then we turn out the light and realize
yeah i don't know that this is worth
even bringing up right and now we're
back at the beginning
try and decide whether it's even worth
trying
the problem though with the
path charting is number one it it sets
you up to do a lot of talking and very
little listening
um and the second is that
if you're wrong about anything the
minute that something surprising happens
you're knocked off your path and you're
locked in the woods decision tree fallen
uh oh [ __ ]
you're not following the script um and
so i think
i think the the reason that landmarks
understand that the underlying structure
helps is that it gives you some
landmarks so no matter where you get
dropped into the woods you can think oh
we're
whether we're saying it directly or not
we're wrestling over blame and who's
whose fault it is that we're in this
situation
so that's the first reason that
structure is helpful
the second reason it's helpful is that
the answer isn't just to
say everything you're thinking the more
transparent and aligned you can be
between your internal voice and your
external voice the better
however that doesn't mean you should
just
re-explain even louder why you're right
and why this is their fault you don't
just dump that sort of toxic internal
voice into the conversation that's not
going to help
instead the first negotiation is really
a negotiation with yourself
to move from being focused on what i'm
right about
and you're wrong about um to getting
curious about why we see this so
differently so i don't have to pretend i
don't think i'm right i still think i'm
right
but given how obvious it is that i'm
right what the hell is going on with you
that you don't see it that's really
interesting
if i can get curious about that then it
actually shifts my purpose in the
conversation and the purpose of the
conversation isn't to hit you over the
head with how right i am it's instead to
understand why you see it so differently
and why we see it so differently so i
need to show my part too
could you
offer some sample language or tell a
story either one is fine could be
hypothetical or just provide some
language for getting
curious because there's
there's a spectrum of options to choose
from some of which might be passive
aggressive some might be aggressive
aggressive and
with the understanding that you're not
invalidating your conclusion you're just
hitting suspend on voicing that
conviction that you have of being right
and getting curious what might it sound
like to to get curious
yeah
so one of the things that we work on
in our negotiation course
at harvard is um
separating empathy
and assertion
and being high on both in any given
conversation
so you both want to be
high empathy
and curious and
you want to have skilled and clear
assertion like here's how i see it let
me see if i can explain it in a way that
is clear even to myself
as i pull apart why i see it the way i
do
the mistake that we make and this is i
think a little bit of what you're
alluding to is that sometimes we
conflate those two so i'll think to
myself i know i'm supposed to ask a
question so i'll phrase this as a
question
why would you think that
which
which isn't really a question why would
you think that is like that's the
dumbest thing i've ever heard
with a question mark at the end
so
and so what happens is we ask
quote unquote questions that are really
disguised assertions thinly disguised
assertions and you're much better off
just saying gosh that seems crazy but
but what do you see that tells you that
that's true and just naming that i
actually don't agree or i can't imagine
that
pulls apart the assertion and just says
it clearly and then i can ask a genuine
question which is
but gosh i mean most the time you're a
pretty smart guy so why would you like
help me understand that
and then my curiosity becomes more
pure more clean actually and so passive
aggressiveness is actually
unspoken feelings frustrations or
assertions that then leak through
us pretending to be curious
so if everyone's
reasonably dysregulated let's just
imagine
just imagine a world let's just imagine
a world in which you know this this calm
surface that we all maintain at all
times
sometimes falters and
uh two people are getting heated maybe
it's the second or third time that
they've had the same
disagreement or argument
what can someone say to
sort of down regulate
that and get to
curiosity and you already gave perhaps a
few examples but
any other thoughts on how to language
that
um my guess is that you're familiar with
the research by john gottman up in
seattle
and i have some familiarity yeah please
provide a
an overview
yeah well an overview just a connection
to to the question that you just asked
so he invites married couples into his
lab and he invites them to talk about an
issue that's stressful between them to
have a difficult conversation
essentially hooks them up to heart
monitors and videotapes and all of that
and then you know he says that he can
watch for five minutes and predict with
their different numbers based on his
different studies but
90 ish 90 92 accuracy whether they'll
divorce within
three or five years
so
part of the reason i name this is that
for me it really says it's not just that
we have difficult conversations in our
most important relationships
those conversations are the relationship
that if we find a way to have them
productively or
constructively
then the relationship will thrive
whether it's a personal or professional
relationship
and or
is where we start to disengage because
you just don't get it you won't listen
and the relationship starts to fray
so what gottman is listening for are
what are the indicators right that he's
listening for that tell him which
direction it's going to go and one of
them
is
that as a
conversation gets heated and starts to
escalate
one of the spouses
will
often make a joke
but the purpose of the joke is that it's
a invitation to step outside this
argument and to see it for what it is to
see what's happening which is that this
is the conversation we usually happen we
usually have and how it usually goes
and so often it's a little bit of an
inside joke but humor
by the way i listened to your
conversation with anne lamott who i
absolutely adore
she's a treasure she is a treasure um
and what does she call laughter is
carbonated
holiness holiness yeah
so laughter also in the brain just
gives us a little bit of instant
perspective that we suddenly see the
absurdity of our own behavior in many
cases and so it's an invitation to just
name what's happening it's like a meta
move
so for instance with my
husband who also teaches negotiation by
the way so
i'd love to be a fly on the wall for
some of those
yeah you can imagine so we fight about
how we fight like yeah like we usually
have this is like my friend's kids my
friends are therapists and their kids
are like stop therapizing me exactly
exactly exactly so we're like yeah
you're not listening
oh a little most difficult conversations
yeah yeah so that's the fight we have
stopped putting your batman in my face
that's right
that's best alternative to negotiated
agreement folks inside joke yeah yes
yeah exactly that was very nice inside
baseball joke
yeah waving your bat around in a
romantic relationship is not usually a
successful strategy you know there are a
lot of people who would find me very
appealing
but one of the jokes that he and i make
when we have the wherewithal to do it is
like why will you not just admit
i am good and you are bad that is what
this is about right it's about who needs
to apologize whose fault this is etc so
as things escalate your ability to just
name that underlying dynamic sometimes
makes the other person laugh right and
you can step out of it for a moment
and then that gives you the opportunity
to say look
obviously we've had this conversation
several times
i'm not understanding why
fill in the blank i'm not understanding
why what i'm suggesting doesn't make
sense help me under like genuinely help
me understand that
or
i'm not understanding what
you're most worried about here
that often
helps
and it needs to be a genuine ask you
can't say like what are you worried
about
because that's really
a hot question it's like you shouldn't
be worried about anything so why are you
being so stupid as to be worrying about
something
as long as you can
step outside
see oh i'm not being curious right now
and i don't have to pretend
that i agree to do it i think that's
really the key and i don't have to say
there's no truth right but
from where i sit i can only see some of
the pieces of the puzzle
you have the other pieces of the puzzle
and we don't really putting those pieces
on the table for discussion is is how we
figure out what we have to work with and
then at the end of the day we still
might not agree about this but it might
open up new options for how we handle it
can i just say i i
this this is
it's uh rekindling this great interest
in
negotiating but it's not quite
negotiating i mean it is negotiating but
it's like negotiating reality through
in part choice of language i remember
reading
getting to yes
i remember reading getting past no which
i also really
really enjoyed
and
and then of course difficult
conversations i think provides very
flexible framework and approach for
engaging with many many different
situations many different people many
different challenges
but
just the phrasing that you used
with the pieces of the puzzle right that
is something that someone could copy and
paste
and use
themselves i mean i just took notes
because it's a non-automatic
sort of pattern interrupt if that makes
sense whereas and i'll i'll own it i
have a history of
some degree of fire
although i've worked on it for a very
long time now but i i think i am prone
to
want to speak very directly not waste
calories and just get to the point and
in doing so i might ask a question like
what are you most worried about like or
why are you worried about this
right which
but the tone and the
the brevity of the question everything
about the delivery is
not a question what
like like for [ __ ] sake why are we
doing this again that is really what i'm
saying what is wrong with you that is
like yeah i have a list of possible
things wrong with you that i've
collected over the years but i'm just
curious which one it is this time yeah
so um
yeah so yeah i i try to have a few
questions in my back pocket to reach for
because in the moment of course you
don't feel like being curious at all so
help me understand what you're worried
about or what might be at risk here
what am i missing
what am i missing is actually a great
question partly because they're going to
be so thrilled to be able to tell you
that they're gonna they're gonna take
that invitation
um but genuinely they can see things
that you can't
i mean it reminds me i sometimes tell
this story about my my eldest son his
name is ben he's 22 now but but when he
was about three
we were driving down the street and
we stopped at a traffic light and we
were working on
both colors and also um traffic rules
because at the time we lived on kind of
a busy street in cambridge
so we're stopped at the light and i say
hey ben what color is the light and he
says
it's green
i said well then we're stopped at the
light what color is the light take a
good look and he goes it's green
and when it turns he says it's red let's
go
now
the kiss seemed bright in most other
ways
so i just thought like what is what is
going on with him like
my first hypothesis is
maybe he's colorblind
right which then that would be my
husband's fault at least i thought at
the time was my husband's father since
been informed it would have been my
fault
but i so i start collecting data right
i'm running a little scientific
experiment of my own and so i started
asking him to identify red and green in
other contexts and he gets it right
every time
and yet
every time we come to a traffic light
he's still giving me opposite
answers because i get a little obsessed
with this
my second hypothesis by the way is that
he is
screwing with me right which i certainly
had some data too
to support
but it wasn't until this went on for
about three weeks it wasn't until maybe
three weeks later and i think my
mother-in-law was in town so i was in
the back seat sitting next to ben
and we stopped at a traffic light and i
suddenly realized that from where he
sits in his car seat he usually can't
see the light in front of us because the
headrest is in the way or it's above the
level the windshield right windscreen as
they say in europe
so he's looking out the side window at
the cross traffic light
now
just think about the conversation from
his point of view he's looking at the
light it's green
i'm insisting that it's red and he's
like you know my mother seems bright in
most other ways but she's just wrong
about this
and the reason that that experience has
stuck with me all these years is that
it's such a great illustration
of the fact that where you sit
determines what you see
and when you're in the front seat
in a position of leadership and i've got
the i've been driving for however many
years at that point i've never had an
accident i've got the resources i've got
the map i've got the view of the road
and somebody in the back seat pipes up
to say something doesn't make any sense
at all
it's just so easy to dismiss it and move
on rather than to say
oh okay it doesn't make any sense help
me at least understand what you're
looking at because often people in the
backseat can see something coming at you
you know that's going to side swipe you
because they're closer to the customer
they're closer to suppliers etc
and i have to say that this that
experience is also coming back to me
these days as i think about the
conversations that we're having about
race
because from where i sit
as a
white person in the united states
i see a lot but there is a whole lot
that i don't see
or that i don't interpret the same way
and
the idea that i've been missing things
all these years and not seen things that
have been systematically unjust
like violates my sense of identity
and i feel ashamed
and yet that shame shouldn't keep me
from
learning more about what else i don't
see
and i think that's one of the reasons
those conversations are so hard
and so important
and now in a situation whether it's i
mean it could be any context right it
could be race related it could be
with
a child not necessarily in the car
context but right
in a situation where
there seems to be a clear disconnect
in the sense that
the two parties are seeing things
not just differently but perhaps seeing
different things yes yeah are there
other
tools or suggestions for how to
sort of open the aperture so that uh
both sides get a better understanding of
what
they are
seeing completely or incompletely yeah
yeah in chapter two we talk about a tool
that actually comes from colleagues of
ours at the business school
at harvard business school so and and
mit um don shearn and chris ardrus
creates something called the ladder of
inference
and it just maps the way that our brains
take in and process information
so at the bottom of the ladder
is sort of all the data all of the
things we can directly experience
and so when when i was telling the story
about ben it's partly that he has
information i don't have
it is actually available to me
technically it's just that i wouldn't
tend to look there
so at the bottom of the ladder is what's
available to me
um and what's available to
others
and
some data won't be available i wasn't
there when you had the conversation with
the
board member or whatever right so you
have information i don't
at the first run of the ladder up it's
of the data available to us we each
select a tiny sliver of it to pay
attention to
and so we might be in the same meeting
but i'm listening for the things that
affect me and are going to ruin my
weekend and that's just not what you're
listening for you're listening for the
things that are going to affect you
and your weekend
and so
in some sense we're attending different
meetings in terms of what we're paying
attention to and and what we remember
and then one more rung up after data
selection is um interpretation what do
we make of it how big a deal is it based
on our past experiences which probably
are different
what does this represent or what do we
predict about it
um so we're reasoning and interpreting
about it and then we come to conclusions
and then when we get into a difficult
conversation
we tend to trade conclusions that was a
great meeting versus that was a total
waste of time this is a good idea
that seems like a good idea but we've
tried it before and it's never going to
work
so part of
the reason that curiosity and
understanding why we see it differently
helps is that it helps us to
unpack the lower rungs of the ladder to
understand where we diverge
was it was it that we each notice the
same thing but we have different
predictions about how that's going to go
in the future based on or how big a deal
it is and whether it's important enough
that we have to address it right now
those are those are interpretations
so
part of what i'm listening for in a
difficult conversation is i'm just
trying to understand what do you see and
how do you interpret it we each have
implicit rules about how
how the world is supposed to work do we
have different implicit rules here
and then that tells me
why it helps me to put those pieces
puzzle pieces on the table and try to
fit them together understand that some
of them just won't fit and that's okay
that's okay but now i understand why
what you make of it
i don't know if this is a
an opportune time it's i suppose it's
not an inopportune time to ask you
what is meant by a statement against
interest statement against interest yeah
what is that
and how does one how does one
potentially use it yeah so a statement
against interest is is
telling you something that if i was
completely self-interested i would not
admit
like that that last answer was a little
bit rambly and confusing
but if you but if you have the latter
and you can you know if you have the
illustration it's much easier to explain
so
it's owning or admitting something
that
isn't in your interest it might hurt you
right
an apology
is a statement against interest in many
cases
the reason that statements against
interest can be so powerful is that it
it's the fastest way in the research
it's the fact one of the fastest ways to
build trust between people because the
other person thinks well i guess they
must be being honest because otherwise
they wouldn't say that
we talked earlier about not just taking
your internal voice that's focused on
blame and what you're right about and
dumping it into the conversation
the the shift from i'm right to why do
we see this differently
should also be accompanied by a shift
from blame to what we call joint
contribution
and joint contribution assumes look we
each did things and they might have been
totally reasonable things nobody did
something wrong
but we just did things or failed to do
some things that got us here
and it doesn't have to be 50 50 but
if i'm willing to own and be accountable
for my contributions to this problem
that makes it more likely that you'll be
willing to do that as well
and so a statement against interest as i
might own my contribution up front look
you know i think
tim we should have talked about this a
while ago and i should have brought it
up earlier because it's been bothering
me for a while so i apologize for that
but i wanted to talk about
fill in the blank
owning my part of it up front which is
often avoiding or delaying a
conversation is a really common
contribution to a problem that is
festering um signals this isn't about
blaming this is just about understanding
what's going on and trying to make it
better
are there other examples you might be
able to share you know in doing homework
for this conversation
you mentioned apologies and certainly
there are uh good and bad apologies yes
helpful and unhelpful apologies and i
actually might want to come back to that
this is something i'm very much trying
to get better at i don't think i'm the
worst in the world but i'm definitely
not winning any gold medals at the
moment well can we dig into that yeah
sure
now you're sorry you brought it up
aren't you
tell me more about how you think about
apologies and and what makes one good or
bad
effective or
actually ineffective
well obviously this is timely for me so
uh
i think part of the reason i i've been
looking forward to asking you about this
is that
coming back to the ladder of inference i
think that
perhaps i am not paying attention to the
right elements of apologies because my
my self-assessment
is that my apologies are pretty good um
my apologies are amazing they're [ __ ]
amazing i didn't want to be too uh too
you should be much more appreciative
of how good that apology was right i'd
like to thank the academy
i think i'm honestly
simply not seeing
what in this case you know my partner is
seeing
and
what i've noticed is that
content almost doesn't matter or the
content matters but
if my tone is
is implying
i don't have a lot of time for this
and is of a certain intensity or volume
that the words really just don't matter
yeah so there is some just regulation
that i think
needs training on my side
so the the message is not that you're
sorry it's that will this apology make
this
end
i think probably that's probably
yeah right i'm like okay i see this
could drag on for a while yeah
i'm willing to suspend
the conversation of who is right and who
is wrong and i'm willing to apologize if
this just
terminates means we can be done if we
can just move on to something else and
uh stop this particular conversation so
oh that's such a great insight yeah i
and you know i'm not i'm not totally
uh you know knuckle dragger about it
like i i i do i have you'd think after
reading all these
books and so on
that i would be acing this
but i i think that also
i often
jump from
i think my girlfriend wants me to feel
how she feels
more than she wants me to
understand in some analytical way
what is causing
what i view or what maybe we both view
as an issue if that makes any sense yeah
yeah i just generally don't operate with
that as my primary
lens yeah
so so those are some of the things that
that contribute
sometimes i use it right sometimes
sometimes the the apology works
but it's not consistent
so i'm looking for some rules some
guidelines some language
anything that can help me get out of the
remedial class and into the more
the more
consistent oh golly
we are all in the remedial class
honestly um but i was just
sort of
chuckling to myself because your
your frame was the apology works
and that
suddenly made me think
oh that's actually probably a piece of
it which is
if i'm apologizing for my own purposes
to accomplish my own purposes
maybe that's antithetical to an apology
yeah because we could probably make a
really cool list of
the different
things that make an apology
less than apologetic or less than
satisfying so one might be it's really
can this be over yet
another
that i often
make the mistake of doing myself is
look i'm sorry you felt that way
right which is basically you shouldn't
have felt that way
um and what i did was completely
reasonable so the problem is still you
yeah and your over sensitivity
i think that
part of what makes an apology meaningful
is that you are
genuine in owning
something that you've contributed to the
problem
and
that
you're acknowledging the impact that it
had on them so
that third piece of the what happened
story is about why are you acting this
way and the advice the shift in that
category is from i know why you're doing
what you're doing or the flaws in your
character
um that are problematic
to separating intentions and impact
which is that
it it's quite possible and most of the
time we had good intentions
or we had no intention
we just weren't thinking about it and it
had a bad impact
and i think that when someone feels we
owe them an apology maybe they want two
things maybe they they want us to sort
of own and take responsibility for
whatever we contribute to the problem
and they also want us to really see and
care about the impact that it had on
them like to really fully understand it
rather than to explain it away or
continue to believe that it was their
problem and maybe those are the
two key elements
to an effective apology
if you were to
give me the crutches and walk me through
this
any suggestions for
wording and languaging this and also if
i'm reflecting on everything we're
talking about i think another
weakness of mine is
almost certainly that i
in some cases provide an apology that
checks both of those boxes
and then within 10 seconds i say end
dot dot dot dot which is the
sort of counter punch of or not counter
punch or justification or
this is why
i think this is an oversensitive
reaction
so i i have the apology but then i can't
leave good enough alone and then i add
some type of rebuttal or
kind of light body shot to it and that
just
completely removes any benefit of or
most of the benefit of the apology i
think that's probably something that i
also do where i get i get some of the
first part and then i i just keep
talking when i should shut the [ __ ] up
for at least
15 minutes yeah yeah yeah
well and the 15 minutes maybe gives you
perspective on whether you need to say
it but i i don't
i don't want to
actually accept that you don't need to
say it okay maybe you do because
if you're feel still feeling unsatisfied
like there's more here that is at the
heart of it for me that doesn't feel
like it's been acknowledged is not just
you might have done a great job of
acknowledging
her or the impact on her
finally she would say
and there's something that feels
unfinished for you so sometimes it's
that
from an identity point of view you want
her to understand that you had good
intentions and weren't trying to hurt
her or upset her or whatever right
it might be that you feel she also
contributed to this and you haven't you
don't feel like she's taken responsibly
for her part of it and in ongoing
relationships
personal or professional
part of what's hard is that
you know this drives me crazy and you
did it again even though you just
apologized for it a week ago so so
maybe your apology isn't real because
you're still
doing the same thing
yeah and that's the wrestling i mean
john gottman
and his marriage studies suggest that
two-thirds of what we argue about
today we're still going to be arguing
about five years from now
and for those of us who
have been in really long we were arguing
about them five years ago and ten years
ago so
it's
it's more about the ways in which we're
different and how we manage that
and so if you're feeling like
uh i got i i gotta add something it may
be that you feel one of those two things
either the impact on you isn't
acknowledged maybe three things impact
on you doesn't feel like it's
acknowledged you don't feel like she's
owning her part her contribution to the
problem
and or you just want her
you just want to know that she knows
that you had good intentions that you
weren't trying to be a jerk because that
would be against sort of the story you
tell about who you want to be yeah in
the world and in the relationship i
don't know what do you think about all
of that
i i think those those are all pieces of
it and i'll i'll give you a little bit
more of of the script okay so awesome if
you're like tim give me your script for
a very uncomfortable
evening right before bed like what's the
perfect recipe
yep uh well i'll give you
a bit of the play-by-play and then we
can we can go from there so the the way
this often
manifests is
my partner
it's very important to my partner that
she can speak truthfully and not people
please
and
i support that i think that's very
important
sometimes how that shows up is
i feel like i can't share
my truth and if i do she feels compelled
to apologize and then feels resentful
that she was looking for an apology and
ended up apologizing herself does that
make sense yeah so she'll speak truth i
will often apologize i'm not saying i do
it well but i will apologize
and then i'll say and you know i don't
feel complete
for these following reasons
and
if if you have the right to share your
truth i feel also
that i should have the same right here's
my truth and then
she feels the need to apologize for that
and that sits very poorly because she's
like well wait a second
i was feeling x i came to you
i just wanted a clean resolution or some
uh
demonstration that you're curious and
interested in my experience and then
possibly an apology now i ended up
apologizing
and then
just to complete this nightmare fairy
tale is not a nightmare i'm being
dramatic but
then
i will say i don't need nor am i asking
for an apology
right so like that's not on me
okay wait this this may or may not have
happened recently so it's very fresh in
the mind yes so wait wait to tell rather
than telling us about it
would you be willing to play both roles
say what she said
say what she says and then switch roles
and say what you say back because this
will give us the
rhythm of it
even better than the analysis so how
does how does it start
she's actually very
very diplomatic and
has
generally speaking incredible
emotional regulations so she will
when it goes well i would or when it is
when it goes better i would say
she will ask something like could we
have could we set a time to talk for a
little bit and then we set a time okay
so hold on when she says i'll be her can
we set a time to talk
what are you yeah right you say sure
what are you thinking to yourself
and feeling
ah [ __ ] here we go yeah yeah exactly
good
but but but but that's uh that's okay
that's okay no i'm not saying that
that's bad
yeah it's just that
yes of course and then you're already
worried about it is
part of what we're exploring so yeah i
mean i think i'm but i think i'm
avoidant in that way
or i'm just like god life is busy enough
like i don't i don't want to deal with
this right now but
but but i'll set a time and or we'll set
a time we'll figure out a time and in
those cases when i know there's an end
time also this is very important for me
and i know i'm still on the analytical
side but like if a conversation erupts
spontaneously and i'm like this could go
for three hours if this doesn't end
right like this this could go
indefinitely
i get very agitated yeah or i make
myself very agitated just to own
the state
okay
uh if it comes up spontaneously
then
i'm already
kind of looking for the exits uh
and then
she'll very often say something like
when x y and z happened
i make up the following story
i'm not saying it's true i'm not saying
you're wrong but the story i make up
she's very good about this
which really removes a lot of the
defensiveness
from me at least
the story i make up is
a b and c whatever a b and c is that you
fill in the blank because you
wanted
or couldn't stand blank blank blank is
that what the story sounds like yeah or
you i mean you did x y and z because you
don't think about me and you make
unilateral decisions about these types
of things and my input isn't important
i'm making that up but that's the
general template yep yeah it could be a
real example and what do you feel when
she says that
it depends on the instance so i i would
say that there are some times when
i immediately feel badly and i recognize
that she's right yeah right it's like
totally on point i was just addicted
sorry like i was busy or over
caffeinated under slept who knows maybe
all the above so there are times i'm
like you're totally right and then there
are other times where i think i'm often
so concerned especially if it's right
before bed i'm like oh god like i gotta
i gotta like nip this in the bud with
this camp go on because i want to go to
sleep yeah yeah exactly where
i will
let's see what would i say i might say
something like
i'll tell you what's going through my
head just to give you a window into it
let's go ahead so what i'm what i'm
trying to verbalize which maybe you can
do a better job of because you've had
front row seats to so much of this i am
very hesitant to say i'm sorry i made
you feel x because i don't believe we
ever make someone else feel a given way
and i think that's a very disempowering
phrasing to use with yourself or anyone
else which is why i said like i made
myself agitated right yep
because there are people friends of mine
for instance like my friend matt
mullenweg who's
he's like the buddha sitting on a lotus
flower in the middle of a hailstorm at
any given time like he's so calm i don't
think he would respond the way that i
did so
i want to own that there are probably
choices and maybe some genetics but
involved
so i i don't want to say
i'm sorry for making you feel x
so usually i'll say something like i'm
sorry if i wasn't thinking
if i wasn't choosing my words carefully
enough and i said something
in a way
that it came off as a b or c i'll say
something like that and
if i just stopped there it would
probably be fine
yeah yeah yeah yeah but you can't quite
leave well enough alone because what
feels unfinished well what feels
unfinished is
i i generally operate in a world with
people who have
very high
degree of
toughness and resilience and grit i'm
not saying she doesn't have those things
she does but
the the people i spend a lot of time
with are you are very
most of my closest friends are very
thick skin yeah and
so i don't feel like i have to
be delicate around them or walk on
eggshells and i resent
when i have to do that because it turns
like a 20-second conversation into a
20-minute conversation and
uh fatigue is something that i have
grappled with my whole life like extreme
chronic fatigue and i think it could
have something to do with having had
lyme disease twice
growing up on long island and you know
east coast how that works but
who knows i've no idea what the reasons
are but i'm very
sensitive to that so i'll i'll say
something like that
and then i'll very often ask something
like is there more right which is from
harvard and helen hendricks imago work
and so on you can see we've done
a fair number of workshops and read a
fair number of books so i'll say you
know is there more and we'll do that for
a bit and then
i will usually feel tension in my body
because
i feel like the exchange is completely
one-sided and
i have my own perspective on what
happened and maybe why it was reasonable
maybe why in fact it was really generous
and charitable and
super light light touch like actually
i've heard what i wanted to say
yeah
yeah right if you thought what i said
was harsh it was much less harsh than
what i wanted to say yeah
that's sort of the the script that's
totally that would be an example of how
it unfolds and i should say
i'm not
convinced that i am right and she is
wrong like that's not what i'm saying no
but but i am convinced that these
exchanges very often end up feeling
unfinished
and
presenting sort of a bitter aftertaste
yeah for us with some regularity it's
not all the time like i think overall
we're doing a really good job as a
couple and
doing all this stuff right like but
um like we're
we're kind of meeting things head-on and
i don't think we're avoiding much
nonetheless these exchanges i find very
draining
yeah so
well i can imagine any words of wisdom
would be most appreciated and because
like one option is if i just want to
preserve the piece if i just want to
if i just want her to feel better then i
won't share my side right but then i
just sit there see things i'm like hey
why the [ __ ] do we do this right before
bed b yes now i get to sit here and like
one of us gets to share our truth and
then i get to censor myself which for a
lot of reasons
from childhood experience and trauma and
all this yes stuff we don't necessarily
have to get into like self-censoring in
that way is is just toxic it's not an
option for me yeah it's very corrosive
so that's that'd be an example yeah
that's a great example can pan out
there's so much there's so much there
that we could unpack um
one one observation is
and and i'm speaking partly from my own
experience being married to someone
where we have very different
norms
for how
harsh or direct to be
and so
the fight
for us and and i hear it a little bit
and what you're describing is the fight
is a little bit about
what is the normal level of sensitivity
or insensitivity like how
how thick should
your skin be or my skin be
and you're struggling a little bit about
the norms and the meaning you each make
of them and also
in that moment of like do i just shut up
and try to sleep but the problem is that
my internal voice is saying like i can't
believe you brought this up right before
bed i'm not a bad person you were
totally overreacting my friends would
not be upset by this and so the exchange
is all empathy on your part and no
assertiveness
yeah
but you know from experience that if you
share the assertiveness part you're back
in for the next four rounds yeah which
is exhausting and if i were you i would
be flooded
that whole time just emotionally like
adrenaline
cortisol et cetera which is not helpful
right before bed not helpful
and is hard so you're looking for the
exits is totally understandable
particularly given your childhood
experience
to just find a way
out that feels safer in terms of how you
feel and you know analytically you're
not unsafe but emotionally it's all
there
actually who i adore she and i had a
really interesting conversation last
year about growing up in households
where there is
yelling criticism etc
being really hard and
also we were talking about the fact that
getting yelled at doesn't tend to faze
her
right so she
has the tolerance to stay in a situation
for quite a while because she loves and
adores her dad but he was tough he was
harsh and she learned
the meaning she makes of it is like
oh well i can survive this this is okay
i don't feel
unrespected
or unloved
in the personal context here
and i can put up with it because i have
experience getting to the other side of
it in exchanges with him and that that
has
built
well or grown her a thicker skin
and
i don't know if that feels true for you
also which given what you've endured
i don't have time to get upset by
smaller things
yeah i think with uh just
athletic coaching and
yeah general feedback not not so much
for my parents but uh
most of the training that i've done like
i i actually
not just tolerate but like do really
well with
firm
coaching like i
i
not abusive but like i i like direct
because it's fast yeah
and i'm sure i also
like
positive reinforcement more than i might
recognize but it's never been a
soft and positive has never been my
default yeah so the meaning yeah yeah
both in receiving feedback
so the meaning that you each make of a
tough harsh curt whatever exchange is
really really different yeah
and this is true by the way
it's true with my husband who when
years ago when we were first married my
sister my youngest sister lived with us
for six or seven months
and when she would leave a dish out
he would grab the dish and go to the
bottom of the stairs was three floors
it's like a condo
tall condo and he would yell at the
stairs hey
stink bug that's what he called my
sister stacy
get down here and take care of your damn
dish
and like that was so not my reaction my
reaction is pick up the dish
feel resentful put it in the dishwasher
and seethe
right so because in my household
there wasn't a lot of open conflict my
parents would think for a long time
before they would come and then we would
have a conversation and i might get
spanked by the way
my grandmother gave my mother a board of
education paddle
so but it would never be done in anger
it would be done as a very deliberate
choice right to teach you something
and
and so
there wasn't a lot of open
conflict or harsh
harshness
my husband grew up just in a very
different household where there was
yelling and sometimes harshness and
and so
like you and your girlfriend
we make very different meaning out of
those two things
yeah so where do you go from there yeah
well so
maybe i'll make an observation about her
startup and then an observation maybe an
option for your
decision point so her startup is so
skilled like this is the story i make up
yeah she's very good at it yeah really
good at it
and
with that she's buying space to dump her
internal voice into the conversation
yeah she's saying why you're doing what
you're doing it sounds like is part of
it usually you don't care you made you a
lot of decisions because you don't think
about me
right and i might
suggest
that if she focused more on the impact
on her rather than
your why you were doing what you were
doing even though she says this is story
makeup this is a story makeup about why
you're a horrible person
right
if you want to escalate a conversation
speculating about why the other person
did what they did is one of the most
reliable ways to make them defensive and
angry
yeah right so she's doing a good job of
caveating it to say like i know that i'm
just making this up and at the same time
hearing it can't be easy
so
just the story i make up
maybe is helpful but she might get
further with you if she just said look
you made that decision without
consulting me at all and
it i was both surprised by it dismayed i
wondered whether you
thought i had nothing else i needed to
do or why you did that
especially since you know that that
bothers me
that might be easier to respond to
because she's not speculating about your
intentions which are actually invisible
to her
yeah that's a good point so you're
basically flooded and her story about
you is sort of the worst possible
version at least it is when when it's me
you're selfish and a jerk and
don't care about me
on the back end i wonder whether the
internal family systems ifs
work
might be helpful it's it's related to
the and stance which we talk about in
difficult conversations
which is look there's a part of me that
just
wants to go to sleep and and
thinks you're right
that i should have consulted you
knows that you're right
and there's a part of me that feels like
i do want to stick up for myself a
little bit
yeah
and
i wonder whether you
understand
whatever it is you need to say i wonder
whether you
see me this way because that would be
upsetting
or or whether it's just what you worry
about and and so i think you can use
that language of a part of me just wants
to go to sleep and a part of me feels
like if i stay silent i'm replicating
the silence i had to hold as a kid
sometimes
and that doesn't feel good for us either
or there's a part of me that wonders
whether
this is gonna work because i don't know
if i can i do feel like i'm walking on
eggshells
and
like i think we got to figure that out
yeah
so whatever it is that's the part that
won't let you sleep yeah the giving
voice to the
parts
is is is a good suggestion and for
people who don't understand the
reference uh just quickly
so ifs internal family systems
founded by richard schwartz uh he may be
dick schwartz
the podcast notes i've had him on the
podcast
is a framework for
not just interpersonal
communications but also therapy and
trauma work
where you identify different aspects of
the self that's the internal family part
that's the reference and it's very
very powerful for trauma work that's
where i have the most familiarity
so for people who want more on that they
can just search
my name or
or ifs at tim dot blog podcast that's a
good idea to name it because i it also
it also buys a little bit of time
and it provides a window into
the felt experience without leaping
directly to an argument that's right
it's kind of announcing the players on
the stage before the players start
talking yeah there's a way in which
you're stepping to what we would call
the third position
like to a balcony
to name what's going on yeah could you
say more about that yeah
so we talk about really skilled
communicators and negotiators developing
first position skills second position
skills and third position skills so
first position skills are how self-aware
are you of what's going on for you what
meaning you're making of things
different
emotions you're bringing to the table or
identity issues etc
and can you
share them clearly and skillfully
second position skills are how good are
you at stepping into someone else's
shoes and imagining the world as they
see it and and finding a way to get
yourself to genuine curiosity if i can
get from that's
crazy
to i wonder why you think something like
that which feels crazy well that's at
least a step in the right direction so
those are empathy skills
and also letting them know that you
understand or that you're working to
understand it anyway
and third position skills are can i step
above the fray and name what's happening
like like that's what the
couples are doing in the gottman work
which is to like just admit i am good
and you are bad that's what's really
going on here like you're naming
our usual escalation pattern
so in the book we talk about stepping to
the third position starting a
conversation from the third position
which is i know that you and i struggle
with a difference
or i know we feel differently about how
we talk to each other for instance or
i know that it makes me crazy when the
dishes are not done before everyone goes
to bed and food sits on the table which
i think is disgusting and i know that
after dinner you just want to relax
and so it's your turn to do the dishes
the food does sit i and i wonder what we
should do about that so you're naming
my there's a difference between how i
prefer things and how you prefer things
and the conversation is about
just better understanding that what we
should do about it that that's a
promising way to
start a conversation
it's also related to what we call the
and stance
and there are a couple different kinds
of ands there's
what we call the you me and i know you
prefer it this way and i prefer it
another way
i know that you find it hard when i'm
harsh or direct or make unilateral
decisions
and
i find it hard when you accuse me of
being selfish when i do that since i
don't think that's really what's going
on
what should we do about that
i know you feel upset and betrayed and
let down by me and i feel wrongly
accused and upset and betrayed that you
would think that of me that we can both
be upset at the same time so that's the
yumi and
then there's another thing called a me
me and and this is much more what chick
schwartz i think is talking about which
is that
i love you and admire how skillfully
you've brought this up and care that i
have once again upset or hurt you and
and
i'm also mad at you for bringing it up
now
and i'm
worried and frustrated that i don't
think i'm going to be able to sleep and
i feel partly wrongly accused or
misunderstood at least
and so i feel conflicted
and the feelings if we're going to step
into the feelings conversation part of
difficult conversations
often there's a headline feeling
or there's a feeling i think i'm
supposed to have right now but
underneath that are a whole bundle of
conflicting and mixed feelings and
sometimes sorting them out and i think
this is part of
what dick schwartz is is helping people
do with ifs which is to sort out the
parts of them that feel differently so
it's not just a soupy murky mess yes i
love you and i'm mad at you right now
yeah yeah we sometimes give people two
chairs
and like put the positive feelings here
and in this other chair put the negative
feelings there say what you want to say
to them and when you move between chairs
you need to spend time in each chair and
when you move between chairs use the
word and not but
because usually we'll say i love you but
you're driving me crazy you know that
negates the first statement yeah they
say bud is the great eraser so it feels
like
the first part is just easing in the
second part is what this is really about
when in fact often it both things are
equally true
which is why and helps
so i have to ask
and this is not meant to
provide myself with supporting evidence
for my lesser behaviors
but if it happens to that wouldn't be
terrible but if it incidentally had that
effect
i wouldn't cry about it
did the hey stinkbug get come down here
and clean your dishes
did that work
um yes it did
because
john's reputation in my family is like
and and with most people who know him is
you know he's got some rough edges he
likes to be a little bit provocative
you once you get to know him and
understand his like really beautiful
generous heart and that's a little bit
of a persona that he puts on
for his own entertainment as well as
hopefully others you really adore him
and
so they sort of hear it and make meaning
of it as it is actually intended so
you're saying set expectations this is
important maybe set expectations but
also learn over time so actually it's
interesting because i'm on the more
sensitive side with my husband
so he's harsher than i am
much of the time
because of just the families we grew up
in
i stand on the other side vis-a-vis my
um co-author and business partner
whose name is doug stone doug is much
more sensitive than i am and so i have
the fun of feeling frustrated at how
sensitive he is sometimes
and we've been i mean we've been very
close friends and collaborators
um for 28 years or something probably
coming up on 30 years now
more than 30 years since 1991 30 years
so
every once in a while we'll have an
argument
or really be frustrated genuinely
frustrated with each other and what he
says happens when that
happens is that he basically goes home
and thinks like well it was a great
friendship but i guess it's over like
i'm just gonna i'm gonna erase you from
my favorites my speed dial favorites and
i guess i'm gonna have to figure out how
to move on and find someone else to
collaborate with because for him
an argument like it would have to be so
bad
to get it out on in the open
and for someone to be frustrated with
him is a huge identity issue for him so
from his perspective it's over and then
you know like an hour later i'll call
him and he's like why are you calling me
we're not friends anymore
um
i'm like what are you you're like it's
just tuesday again i know we do this
once a week yeah i i mean it actually is
relatively rare but but i'm still
thinking like what are you talking about
like of course yeah we're frustrated
with each other that's normal
and we'll figure it out like i probably
am not really seeing what you're trying
to tell me or why this makes sense
so the meaning i make of it is like good
friends can be
can talk it through
and the meaning he makes of it is good
friends don't have fights
so what do you say
what do you
and you've known each other for so long
maybe maybe you skip the pleasantries uh
uh the the formalities but
what do you what do you say after one of
these
flare-ups what would your best self
say
my best self
my best self wouldn't have called an
hour later i would have waited a little
longer
so that i could see my part of it um
my best self
when she shows up
does
tend to start with what i think i've
contributed to the problem
and how do you introduce that
which is often that i get when i get
frustrated i the place i tend to go is
like
bossy dictatorial like look this is just
we don't time for this this is what
we're gonna do and as an oldest sister
it's really a strength of mine to be
bossy when people say i'm boss i'm like
well if you would listen to me your life
would be going so much better so i don't
see what the problem is but i think i
see my own patterns and
i'm willing to own them
like look i i know that i am feeling
maybe freaked out or anxious that we're
not going to finish this on time let's
imagine we're working on a chapter that
isn't working
um and by the way we're we're re-working
difficult conversations now like as we
speak um
we're doing a third edition so i've got
my my book here with all my
notes and markups and look at that
what have we learned since
what didn't we include what's missing
etc so when we're writing together
doug is really good at taking things
apart and letting them be messy for a
while because
he has a sense or we both have a sense
like this isn't quite right but we can't
figure out what's wrong with it
he's really good at taking it apart and
taking it apart and making letting it be
messy again where we don't
see the way out from a writing point of
view makes me very anxious
yeah i know the feeling yeah when you've
taken everything out of your closet off
the hangers and put it in the middle of
the floor and you're like well now what
the [ __ ] do we do
exactly it's like look the chapter had
10 things that were really working about
it
and one or two that we sensed were not
quite right so why did we have to throw
out the 10
but sometimes you got to throw out the
10 you got to kill your darlings because
otherwise you're not going to see
what it is that's wrong you've got to
rebuild it
and
he's really good at at
being more comfortable with the
rebuilding the tearing down especially
and
so i'll
maybe start with
look i know
that part of what's driving me is i just
am incredibly anxious i'm totally
freaked out that we're not going to
figure this out
so i'll just
own what are the feelings
that are
driving me to be so insistent
about what we need to do so there is
some first position like self-reflection
and what am i contributing to the
problem stuff going on that
i'll be willing to own
and that usually
one of the strongest um
norms in the literature the research
literature is is reciprocity so if i
attack you you're going to attack me
back
yeah and if i am willing to own my part
of this
i make it easier for you to be willing
to own yours
if you don't
how do you bring up someone else's
contribution sometimes you can do it as
a request hey i don't know if this would
be possible but would you be able to
fill in the blank implicitly i'm asking
you to change something because what
you're doing now isn't helping from my
point of view but i'm framing it not as
a would you knock it off but instead
would you be willing to do something
different
and that sometimes helps especially when
you're talking up in hierarchy hey boss
if you could give me a heads up before
the meeting i could probably
be better prepared to answer your
questions in the meeting
would that be possible rather than
ambushing me but you don't add the last
rather than ambushing me part
one approach that i've
read about this is this is also i think
a weakness of mine is
presenting things as a shared problem
not
immediately offering
or asking for a particular solution
could you
speak to that maybe give an example
or just elaborate
yeah
yeah i think that that's and actually we
dig into this a little bit more in the
feedback book
um the feedback book has a chapter on
relationship thanks for the feedback
thanks for the feedback
it has a chapter on relationship systems
and the way that in relationships
working relationships or personal
relationships
often we each have feedback for the
other about how we think the other
person needs to change like you have
feedback from me that's hilarious
because the problem here is clearly you
and obviously that's part of what's
happening here as well
because the problem isn't that there's
something wrong with me or something
wrong with you is that the combination
of the two of us is a little bit of a
struggle on some front
so that's a shared problem for us to
figure out if we're going to continue to
collaborate
live together
be in a relationship
what should we do about that
and
i do think that a lot of difficult
conversations are about the argument
who's the problem here
and if instead it's the combination of
us is part of what we're each struggling
with that's a much better frame
yeah it's there is no
target that can become
defensive right it's objectified
in a way
yeah and it's each of us standing on one
side with the problem in front of us
rather than standing across from each
other
pointing
to each other as the problem
could you speak to
blame absorbers versus blame shifters
and maybe there are some other
categories i don't know but those two
yeah
so our
one of our observations is that if when
you make the shift from blame to
thinking about things in terms of
contribution it's not just that you're
using a nicer word
blame assumes
that somebody did something
what they did
didn't
measure up on some yardstick of what was
appropriate what was professional what
was expected what a good person would do
right and so they fell short in some way
or did something quote unquote wrong
and therefore
the question is how should they be
punished
and
you know occasionally punishment is
formal like they're fired
but
more often punishment is informal who's
in the doghouse who has to make it up to
who
um who has to apologize
and
if we're going to so it's no
surprise that people try to avoid being
tagged with the blame
but they also avoid being tagged with
the blame because in most situations it
wasn't just me
i was reacting to what you were doing
um and so contribution
shifts
to come from a really different
assumption
which is that
wherever we're at right now which is the
problem which is a problem
we each did or failed to do some things
that got us here and
that going forward if we want to improve
that understanding what we each
contributed is the way to actually
change things and improve them
so
i think that looking for what am i
contributing to this problem
is
part of what
empowers me to know what i could change
or try to do differently
now this i went on a little bit of a
tangent which is background for your
original question you want to state your
question
well i was just gonna ask if a sort of
perverse maybe that's a strong word but
an exaggeration of that is
the blame absorber yes
so
if we're talking about what do we each
contribute to this
i think that each of us leans in a
particular direction
blame absorbers are quick to see what
they
have screwed up so the first place
they're going to point the fingers of
themselves like i should have seen this
coming i should have said something
earlier i can't believe i let myself get
into this situation again
and blame shifters are the opposite
they're gonna see everybody else's
contribution first like i'm late because
the traffic was terrible because you
know my kid wouldn't put their shoes on
because zoom wasn't working correctly
etc so their first instinct is to point
a finger away from themselves
either to the situation or to other
people
and you would think god should be great
to be a shifter because nothing is ever
your fault but the experience of being
shifted is basically the experience of
being victimized by the world and
everybody else in it because you don't
see your part and so it's actually very
disabling yeah
if you're an absorber i think we're all
taught to be absorbers particularly as
leaders like take responsibility the
buck stops here
the problem is that if you're a true
absorber
in doing so often you let other people
off the hook you take responsibility for
everything like my mother tends to be an
absorber like if there's an argument at
dinner she'll think oh i should have
served something else or i'm sorry she
apologizes when the weather is bad when
i visit it's like mom i don't think you
were really responsible for the weather
although she told me recently we were
talking about this and she said oh i'm
i'm not really an absorber i'm just a
social absorber i know that's what i'm
supposed to say but inside we both know
it's your fault
[Laughter]
so absorbers and shifters often
will find each other in relationships
or in the workplace because it's the
perfect relationship right we both agree
it's the absorber's fault
but over time what happens is the
absorber gets fed up and tired of being
the one who always apologizes and tries
to fix things and and takes
responsibility and being the bad guy and
so
it's a stable system until it's not
yeah so part of the reason that this is
all important is just to reflect on your
own
pattern
what you see first and contribution
balances whatever you see if you see
your own part first well remember it's
not all you
if you can't fix this by yourself you
can't be the hero and fix something by
yourself
you you need to think about what would
other people need to change if we're
really going to have change and vice
versa of course
i think this is related to those roles
of hero villain victim
yeah yeah for sure do you want to speak
to that
yeah i was just
in the back of my mind i was thinking
about
the ways that these two things overlap
which i
have been thinking about recently
because
the hero is often an absorber
who says you know i'm going to come in
and save the day if i
change this
and i'm a good leader who takes
responsibility
now it could also be that the hero is a
shifter nothing's ever their fault
because they're only a good guy this is
related to identity
so it'd be interesting to hear how you
think about that the villain role nobody
wants
and when people
attribute negative intentions
to you or yeah you're the problem
nobody wants to play that role in the
conversation that's why
starting from the third position
helps like this is just the difference
between us nobody's the villain here
or nobody's the problem
yeah and for people who want more
context on this one option
might be a podcast episode i did with uh
jim detmer
d-e-t-h-m-e-r and i think
i'm sh
he likely refers to this from someone
else i can't remember the originator
maybe you do but the drama triangle yeah
the drama triangle
and puts these three perspectives into
practice
for problem solving and
his website is i think it's conscious
dot is
or something along those lines but if
you look up the
conscious leadership group
and jim demmer i'm pretty sure they have
pdfs on their website that people can
find related to the drama triangle which
i do find interesting i find practicing
that
where sometimes you're instructed to
stand in each spot and verbalize each of
those perspectives to be very
challenging
i don't i i do not have much of a flare
at least not intentionally for the
theatrical
my girlfriend would probably disagree
yeah but
intellectually i find it useful to
think about and journal on but to
actually practice live by standing onto
those spots in front of someone like a
therapist i find it incredibly hard yeah
it can be really hard it's it's
interesting for me because when i listen
when you are a third party
like in this conversation and you were
describing your conversations with your
girlfriend
i'm a third party listening to that
any of us when we're a third party
listening to someone else's conflicts
it's easier to hear in it
like oh i see what they each think that
they're right about i see what they're
each contributing to the problem i can
hear the ways in which they each feel
accused of being a bad person or having
bad intentions and they're each
really wanting the other to understand
the impact that this has had on them
and they're each full of frustration and
hurt and
confusion and anxiety and adrenaline
and maybe they're wondering am i a good
partner am i a good person am i worthy
of love am i broken in some way that
needs to be fixed i hear the other
person wanting to me to fix myself it's
not just they want to fix me they think
i should fix myself
as a third party you can hear all of
that
and you can also hear oh i hear someone
playing the victim role here that in
storytelling human storytelling often
those three roles show up right any
disney movie is gonna have a hero a
villain and a victim or set of victims
and we each can fall into those
roles in how we tell our own stories as
well
so if you want to get better at this
often listening to other people's
stories and asking them questions about
what what do you feel like you
contributed or what do you feel you're
right about and what does the other
person think they're right about
the most common pattern is actually we
each actually might be right
we're just talking past each other right
your girlfriend might be right that she
well clearly she's right that she felt
hurt or overlooked
or this isn't how she would like to be
whatever talk to etc
you're right that you didn't do it on
purpose and that it wasn't
that big a deal
in the grand scheme of life
for me for you
and that if you're going to be in a
relationship with her it actually is a
big deal for you guys to figure out how
to navigate right so if the problem is
between us it's a shared problem of how
we will figure this out
yeah so
i think the
challenge is that in our own conflicts
it can be so much harder to see
yeah
like when you're standing in that place
describing to a therapist it's really
hard to see our own patterns and that's
the challenge of getting better at
difficult conversations
yeah you mentioned the disney movie
having all three which is so true and i
can't remember
the source but i i remember listening to
someone
they were talking about how we create
drama in our own lives because we we
want our lives to be the most
interesting movie imaginable no one
wants it just to be a snoozer so we we
create these stories and figures and so
on and i was just thinking to myself
maybe all of our stories
have
hero villain victim and if you can't
find one that's who you are that's the
role that you play and maybe that's a
way of backing into it
oh that's beautiful yeah i also find it
sometimes useful that useful if i think
how in the world do they tell this story
can i tell
their perspective
putting them in the hero role yeah
because they do feel like they're the
hero of their own story in most cases
have you ever seen that's an old movie
it's an akira kurosawa film rashomon yes
it's wonderful if anyone listening
has not seen russian one i want to go
see that again it is an entire film
where the same events are told through
the eyes
and perspectives of different people in
the film it's it's a beautiful beautiful
film it's a beautiful film i'll add one
more film if you're curious about hero
villain victims which is please um
shattered glass
never heard of it
so it's about stephen glass who made up
those articles
he wrote for the
new republic was that it i can't recall
so it's a big scandal and hayden
christensen was he the guy who played
anakin
i'm more of an episode four kind of guy
so it could very well be but that actor
the actor that actor
of course i brought up a movie that now
i can't remember clearly to describe but
the the point of it is that he
stephen glass in real life
was so good at playing the victim
that
he had colleagues and friends stepping
in to
cover for him when people got suspicious
who would say to the editor-in-chief
like don't why are you being so mean why
are you doubting him of course this is
true you know why are you coming down on
him so hard he's very sensitive and
he was so good at playing the victim
that he had other people enlisted as
heroes who would intervene to help cover
for him and it's a fascinating and
beautifully done
movie
shattered glass do you come away feeling
depressed is it a beautiful but downer
of a movie what should people be
emotionally prepared for
i came away feeling fascinated
got it i came away feeling fascinated
with the way in which he so effectively
managed those conversations for so long
and the way that he cast the editor who
was
who started to be suspicious and ask
harder questions and demand to see his
notes and why weren't you you know
tell me when this happened they cast him
as the bad guy
and so it's been also helpful for me
when i feel like i'm being the bad guy
because i'm being too harsh or demanding
or suspicious or something
is that just the story that's being told
are my questions and concerns justified
because i can be very
vulnerable to not wanting to be the bad
guy
yeah and it causes me to not want to
have conversations sometimes
wow
well
sheila if you'd be interested i i think
we will probably need to do or i would
like to do a round two at some point uh
we have many more things we could speak
about oh yes yes for sure
we've only
covered a small percentage of the
terrain
difficult conversations is the book that
has come up many times in this
conversation how to discuss what matters
most and then
the book that we spent a little bit of
time
kind of poking at from
oblique angles thanks for the feedback
the science and art of receiving
feedback well your consulting group is
triad consulting group which people can
find at triadconsultinggroup.com
is there anything else that you would
like to say any closing comments
requests of the audience anything at all
that you would like to add before
we close this round one
oh gosh
maybe just if you're having difficult
conversations
in your life with yourself and with the
people around you
that you're not alone
and that they
they're part of being human and being in
relationships but they also
are an indicator that you care a lot
about what you're doing and you care
about the people you're doing it with
and so in many ways it's a sign of
health
and so for me that's been part of what's
been
so rewarding about this work is that you
meet someone and you get to know them
pretty well very quickly because we go
straight to the edge of what they're
coping with and not sure how to handle
and struggling with
and for someone who's naturally pretty
shy
myself
i i have found that such a
such a beautiful and rewarding
open door
so for everybody that for you tim just
in this conversation and also for
everybody
that i've had the privilege of working
with over the last 30 years it's like
they let me into
part of their life that really matters
and the conversations that matter to
them
um and if if that's if that's where we
live together in our relationship like
i'm there
i'm totally there
well sheila this has been so much fun
and very helpful i took a lot of notes
and there are many things i'll be
following up on and uh maybe some some
lines that i'll rehearse later in the
mirror like before i go on stage
into into this evening
and
this has been tremendously helpful i
hope we have another opportunity to
continue the conversation
and
what a gift to be able to spend time
together so thank you so much thank you
and to everybody listening as always we
will have links in the show notes to
everything that we discussed all the
books
all the films all of the everything any
particular concepts any names at
tim.blog
podcast so you can just search
h-e-e-n and that episode this episode
will pop right up and until next time
measure twice cut once with those harsh
words
do some thinking
nice try to take the third position
and thanks for tuning in
hi tim it's sheila
you know as i thought about our
conversation
afterwards of course i thought of all
the things i wish i would have asked
or
had insights i wish i would have thought
of at the time
and you know that's normal
the good news and the bad news of
difficult conversations is that they're
usually happening
in ongoing relationships over time and
so it's not so much about having exactly
the perfect script or thing to say in
the moment as much as it is about having
an ongoing conversation so in the spirit
of an ongoing conversation
i thought i would offer a couple of
thoughts i had afterwards just in case
they might be helpful to you
so the first is that one of the
questions that sits underneath many many
difficult conversations it's sort of the
background music to the conversation or
maybe a low hum ominous hum
below the surface
is the question is this going to be okay
are we going to be okay
is this conflict going to
mean consequences
or even the end of the relationship when
someone raises something important to
them with someone else
part of what they're asking is is this
the kind of thing that we can talk about
talk through
and resolve together
and you know particularly given
gottman's research about you know
two-thirds of our
conflicts in long-term relationships are
not really resolvable
the task isn't to resolve them once and
for all it's to figure out a way to
handle them or navigate them and manage
them together
that feels
okay and good
and i think part of
what might be happening when your
girlfriend comes and says hey can we
talk
is she saying i want to raise something
that's happening that's actually not
okay with me
and
if i were in your shoes and maybe if i
was in her shoes i would be thinking
and what does this mean for us is this
going to work
are we going to be able to figure out
how to navigate this together
and you might be
feeling like
gosh what you're asking me to do is do
to be perfect and
i have already demonstrated that that is
not going to happen
so if i continue to sometimes
misstep or
be an [ __ ] like is that going to be
okay
and so i think that's going to raise the
stakes for both of you in the
conversation and i wonder whether
there's a way to turn down the heat or
maybe the volume on that
question at least for a while
a second thing and i have a thought
about how to do that but let me add a
second thing that i have been thinking
about that
is related which is
when she comes and says
hey can we talk
the implicit
topic or purpose of that conversation is
singular it's about her
topic
and when
you ask the question is there more
which by the way is a fantastic question
and
it may unintentionally reinforce that
the whole purpose of this conversation
is about your
concern or feeling hurt or impacted by
me
and in addition is there more
it's putting everything on the table all
at once like leave no stone unturned
it's like you're doing spring cleaning
every evening that you have this
conversation rather than just a light
spot dusting
in the relationship
and i'm not sure you need to do a spring
cleaning every evening
and so i wonder whether we can
do a couple of things
one is
reassure each other that that question
are we going to be okay
is answered yes we are going to be okay
and we're going to figure out how to
handle this
to turn down the power on that
conversation or the heat
a second is can we
expand the frame on what your
conversation is about beyond just her
topic because if it's just her topic
then when you can't help yourself and
you add your perspective it feels
disruptive or off topic
when i think actually the frame of the
conversation should be hey i noticed
something today
that i want to talk about that's one of
those places where we have some rub or
some friction
and i want to tell you about it
and
can we expand it to say oh great and i'm
really interested and then i would love
to
you know share what was going on with me
in that moment so the purpose of our
conversation isn't just hearing you out
so that you can speak up and not people
please which is total i totally support
i love that about how you support that
with her
but also
and then i'll add like what was going on
for me and we can kind of figure it out
together so it's framing the purpose of
the conversation as just understanding
maybe there'll be an apology in one
direction or another but maybe it's just
about oh
cool this is one of those moments let's
just unpack it a little bit
and notice
what is happening and talk about if
neither of us changes a whole lot
what could make this better what small
things might be able to make this better
and so you might do a 60-day experiment
that when she comes and says hey can we
find a time to talk
your automatic response should be ooh
yes awesome i can't wait
and and i can't wait to hear what you
have noticed and i'll add what i noticed
in that moment and maybe we'll better
understand this
and that actually
hopefully lowers the stakes and changes
the frame to be a little bit more
inclusive
and also treats it a little bit more
like a spot dusting i suppose we're
going to keep that metaphor
and at the end of 60 days
just see whether the
tenor of these conversations has changed
the last thing
that i will say is of course the timing
of when you're having the conversations
as we talked about a little bit is kind
of disastrous for you
and i'm sure that when she says can we
find a time to talk you're picking the
end of the day because obviously you
both have a ton of other stuff to do
during the day
but i wonder whether that's exactly the
wrong time i know it's always the wrong
time for me
so often i hear the advice from long
partnered people like don't go to bed
mad or
don't let the sun go down on your anger
is something my grandmother would have
said
and that seems like good advice except
that in practice it's horrible advice
because the end of the day is exactly
the time especially if we're irritated
with each other it's exactly the time
when like i've been carrying around and
adding to the list of
my partner's flaws and problems and
i'm tired i'm irritable i have exactly
zero energy or patience to do the hard
work of listening
and it is hard work to listen to someone
tell you something that you've done that
has upset them or
to feel misunderstood and to try to
properly accurately understand each
other that's actually hard work so
the last thing i would add to your 60
day experiment should you decide to
accept this
mission this mini mission
would be not to have them at bedtime but
just to find a time maybe when you're
each at your best in terms of energy and
to treat them as like quicker check-ins
earlier in the day
to try to understand for each of you
what's going on there and over time to
start noticing those patterns
the end of 60 days if you like we can
get together and talk about feedback and
we'll see how it went
anyway tim thank you so much for the
conversation i so enjoyed it and i can't
wait to hear what happens next good luck
you